تعهدتنا امريكيه متكرره بالدفاع عن
الجزيره التايوانيه في حال اقدمت الصين
على غزبها ولكن السؤال هل واشنطن قادره
اصلا على تنفيذ وعودها اتجاه تايوان خبراء
عسكريون امريكيون اجابوا على هذا
الاستفسار وحذروا من عدم استعداد بلادهم
لمواجهه حرب المحتمل مع الصين في ظل
افتقارها للصواريخ بعيده المدى فالقاذفات
الامريكيه مشاهدينا ستحتاج بين الف والف
صاروخ طويل المدى مضاد للسفن للبقاء على
مسافه امنه نسبيا فيما المخزون الامريكي
الحالي اقل من 250 صاروخا ومع الدعم
الامريكي العسكري الضخم نياب وبمعدل
الانتاج الراهن سيصل البنتاجون الكميه
المطلوبه بحلول عام 2035 على اقل تقدير
فاذا تامين الصواريخ مستحيل هذا وحتى
الخبراء واشنطن على النظر في وضع الذخائر
مسبقا في تايوان صعوبه امدادها لاحقا خلال
الصراع على عكس اوكرانيا صحيفه تايمز
البريطانيه نقلت عن منتدى المحيط الهادئ
سيناريوهين مرعبين لتداعيات سقوط تايوان
في ايدي بكين تحت عنوان العالم بعد سقوط
تايوان سابدا بالحديث عن السيناريو الاول
بماذا يتمثل يتمثل بسقوط تايوان دون قتال
شامل وايضا دون مساعده دوليه وبموجبه تدخل
في محادثات سلام لكن الغزو الصيني يستمر
اثناء المفاوضات لحين سقوطها بالكامل اما
السيناريو الثاني فيشمل سقوط تايوان بعد
معركه داريا ضمت متاخره واشنطن وايضا
حلفائها حينها يكتشف التحالف ان الجيش
الصيني اكثر قدره من الروس في اوكرانيا
ويتكبت خسائر ماديه وبشريه مهوله لكن
سقوط تايوان باي طريقه من الطريقتين وفق
التقرير سيحمل وقعا كارثيا على الولايات
المتحده وايضا على مصداقيتها فحينها سينظر
للصين على انها محرك اساسي واقوى دوله
بالعالم
[موسيقى]